joining me right here on the rich eisens
show my colleague from the nfl media
group
rap sheet himself ian rappaport how are
you sir
what's going on rich how are you well i
just want to let you know before we
continue you're on live television and
radio
uh you know okay just want to let you
make sure you're aware of that
uh um yeah i you know it's funny like i
after you know i reported some julio
things today and sometimes you check on
the twitters to see like
the reaction what are people saying and
i clicked on
the trending topics and one of the
things that was trending was
just did julio as in did julio know that
he was on the air
um and it's a great question i hope that
he did
if he did not there are many many many
many questions about it
um i don't think he said anything
necessarily wrong
probably didn't come off like maybe he
wanted but um did huion know he's on air
is a
legitimate and real question well i mean
because if he did if he did
then the trade demand that you say
that's been uh in the works for
several weeks and months that clearly he
did not go out and say anything about
publicly that his stance has changed
on all of that so like i guess let's get
into
what you tweeted out uh this very
morning that
the all-pro requested a trade from the
organization a few months ago
according to sources the team then
agreed to listen to offer that's how it
began and why it continues
do we know why julio requested a trade
months ago
yeah i i mean it this seems to me and
now
first of all like you know obviously
this is something i've sort of
i would say known
thought very strongly for a couple weeks
and i got this
you know inclination during the draft
when all of a sudden trade talk kind of
popped up out of nowhere
and i never quite could confirm it and
then you know julio going public today
probably helped spread this
spur this along a little bit um
but you know this seems to me to be
somewhat similar to the matthew stafford
situation
right like stafford had played with the
lions he had given everything he had
had some really really good performances
played through injuries
uh been through some stuff some highs
and some
lows and obviously julio probably more
highs than than stafford but it just
seems to be if the organization is
you know they're not rebuilding in
atlanta but they're definitely starting
new
and i'm just not sure that he wanted to
be a part of something
starting new again it feels like he'd
rather
join the team that is already there and
just kind of be the final piece to a
championship that is
my sense of it and you know the the
he he's you know one of the greatest and
has
everything public and publicly and
privately whatever is going on with
julio has been
a plus across the board and the falcons
are treating him like that
i was just to say he wants the trade and
they're saying all right we will
because we respect you we'll see what we
can do well and obviously
there's no r there's no reason to do it
right away
um certainly if the cap ramifications
that the falcons clearly
knew were was coming even without the
cap number
being announced until march that the cap
ramifications
of trading him after june 1 and getting
him someplace new
then in time for training camp is so
much better for the team i mean the
amount of money that they would
save on the cap trading him after june 1
would pay for the rookies that
you were reporting at the draft they
wouldn't be uh able to pay even before
they drafted him
uh because of the cap charge so where
does all that stand what do you think
is going on the phone lines with terry
fontenot certainly now
that julio jones has said the words
publicly
albeit who knows if he knew he was
saying it publicly at the time
he was saying it publicly but uh what do
you think is happening
right now yeah so basically when rumors
come out
that uh a player could potentially be
traded
teams start calling right and so
generally we see like trade rumor
and then it's like teams are fielding
calls right
um and i think with julio around the
time of the draft that happened the fact
that he wasn't traded before the draft
is not a great sign because that would
have been a perfect opportunity
for a team that needed to fill a hole
like trade for julio now
know you have them the trade is
processed on june
2nd for the cap for cap reasons and kind
of move on from there
that didn't happen so for me you know if
the falcons are going to demand a lot
and i know that they are
and should and maybe a more likely
situation is if someone has some sort of
training camp injury
they feel like they have to trade for
julio maybe that
is eventually what gets it done but i
mean the problem with trading
with would just say hey we'll make the
trade now but we'll just we'll just
process it on june 2nd
is you know anything can happen to julio
jones god forbid between may and
and june and somebody's already gotten
the draft choices i mean that's a very
difficult thing to pull off
in the nfl we do see it a lot in the nba
so
um what do you think the the the uh
the cap charge is 15 million for
whatever team that takes them on
according to jeremy fowler chargers
colts 49ers patriots of the teams that
could just do it right now they don't
have to reconfigure anything on their
cap they could just make this deal
and do it and those are four teams that
definitely fits the bill of julio jones
wanting to be a piece
to a possible championship puzzle do you
think that's possible
ian um i i would also say
you know julio does want out which
clearly he's interested in some level on
in a trade my guess is he would probably
redo his deal in a way that would make
it more cat friendly for a team
um so or you know we could also
see what we've seen in the past which is
the falcons would say you know what
we have to get a first round pick it
just has to happen
so we'll pay a little bit of the salary
to make sure that it happened like we've
seen that too
so you know looking at the teams that
could do it cap wise like
i think that eliminates too many because
i think what you what we found for
better or worse is that
the teams in cap trouble are a lot of
times the teams that are good
who have great players they have to pay
and they somehow make it work like i
don't think the falcons would ever trade
them to the saints like why would you
right but the saints have no cap space
for the next 20 years and they probably
could make it work somehow
they just always are able to you know so
i think i think if a team wants them
they will figure out how to do it more
than anything okay before i let you go
for you to tee it up ian rappaport um my
uh
my longtime uh colleague at the
worldwide leader
uh kenny mayne tonight is his last
sports center he has tweeted out
um you know in the past week that aaron
rodgers is going to pay him
a visit as a farewell and as an atta boy
for uh their friendship as kenny's
remarkable career at espn comes to a
close at the sports center tonight
so um the quiet that has uh
fallen on this story since i guess the
kentucky derby
uh may be broken tonight what do you
think uh is going
on with rogers and the packers um and
certainly if aaron does make that
appearance tonight that will be
fascinating but what is the quiet can
you interpret the quiet for me
yeah um first of all i i don't know
anything i mean i know some things but i
don't know anything about what rogers is
going to say
to kenny mayne i have some doubts as to
whether it's going to be substantive or
not
um i mean maybe he does a solid for his
friend and
tells them something but i just i would
imagine it's going to be much
funnier than it is informative okay um
so what we'll see um you know what's
happening now is rogers is in hawaii
uh with his fiancee playing guitar i
believe i saw on social media
um and the packers are moving forward
uh with jordan love at otas i know
they still have had i don't know how
recent the conversations have had but in
the last
several weeks there's been trade
conversation there's been i'm sorry
uh contract conversations negotiations
um i still believe that is the very
serious focus for the packers to get him
a new deal that
gives him some security that he wants um
so to me the quiet means they're trying
um that's what that's as far as i can
tell that is what it means and all of me
and thanks for the time really
appreciate it i want to say one thing
real quick first
sure um so you are a noted
uh fan of breaking bad yes sir i have uh
only recently learned that this is a
great show that i should watch so i'm
now in season two
and i just i just met saul for the first
time who is quite a character uh and i
know
uh that is one of your people um so i
just want to say that i'm enjoying it
immensely and where have i been for the
last decade so when you said you've met
you met saul you mean through the
television not actually bob odenkirk
himself is what you're saying
yes not the real person um but the
character i've just he
he popped up on my uh on my ipad as i
was watching and i'm like oh wow
here we go you're about to have a whole
world unlocked
for you ian where have you been and it
is truly one of the best shows and then
you got better call saul
after that and that the final season of
that is being shot right now you're in
you're in great shape man i'm kind of
jealous to be honest with you
you're in good shape it's one of those
weird things where everyone said it was
so good
and it actually has been as good as
everyone said the fact of the author
it leads uh it it keeps living up to it
it's only going to get better
it really will awesome ian thanks for
the call man you take care all right
thanks for it you got it
you bet hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here